[موسيقى]
وانحيكم مشاهدينا من جديد
على اثنين من كبار المسؤولين الصينيين
وقال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه ان
هذه العقوبات تلحق ضرار خطيرا بالعلاقات
الصينيه الامريكيه من جهه اخرى اكد
المتحدث الصينيه
رفيع المستوى التقى بنائب وزير الخارجيه
الصيني خلال اليومين الماضيين في مدينه
القريبه من بكين دون الافصاح عن نتائج
الاجتماع الجانب الامريكي اعلن ان هذه
الزياره تهدف لترتيب لسياره
العمل الجديد كما انها تسعى لاعاده الطفل
للعلاقات بين البلدين وفي التاسع من
ديسمبر اعلنت الخزانه الامريكيه فرده
عقوبات على عدد من الافراد والكيانات
القانونيه الصينيه وسفن التي ترفع العلم
الصيني بموجب قانون
العالمي وشملت العقوبات الامريكيه شركه
صينيه مرتبطه بصيد الاسماك ومواطنين
الصينيين وعدد من الشركات الاخرى
[موسيقى]
مناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفينا من الرياضه
صحفيه الهنديه لما يكون من واشنطن الدكتور
حسين عبد الحسين المحلله السياسي اهلا بكم
من واشنطن التي عليها انتقادات في الواقعه
دكتور
مع الصين ولكن بعدها بساعات
يفرض عقوبات على مسؤولينا الصينيين البعث
قرا في ذلك همم ضبابيه في الموقف الامريكي
حضرتك كيف تقرا هذه الاجراءات
مساء الخير ستريم انا اقرا هذه الاجراءات
من باب الاضطراب الذي نشده منذ تسلم هذه
الاداره دفت اداره البلاد والسياسه
الخارجيه اييه وهذا الاضطراب يشمل كل
الملفات يشمل الملف الملفات في الشرق
الاوسط ايران اليمن والان نراه في الصين
مثلا في اليمن يعني التخبط واضح لا بديل
عن اعاده الحوثيين الى احد ولكنهم لم
يفعلوا ذلك مع انهم يدينون الحوثيين بشكل
همم يعني متوسط نفس الموضوع في الصين
يقولون دفع العلاقات ثم يفرضون همم عقوبات
لا نعرف من الذي يطرد طبعا يعني عمليه فرض
العقوبات يعني
الخزانه الامريكيه ولكن همم حضرتك لما ترى
ضبابيه من يتحمل مسؤولياتها الرئيس
المحيطون به همم هناك ايضا خفيه تقف همم
هذا الراي والراي المقابل تماما في وقت
وجيز
لا اعتقد ان هناك يعني همم جهه تمارس الشر
او هناك خبث في الموضوع اعتقد ان هناك
اضطراب ان هناك مراهقه في هذه السياسه
طبعا كما تفضلتي الخزانه هي التي فرضت
ولكن اي عقوبات في الدوله الامريكيه تحتاج
الى خمس
وزارات على الاقل بما فيها العدل والدفاع
والخارجيه والخزانه وكل هذه الوكالات
عليها ان توافق يعني هذا الموضوع لا يتم
في غضون اسابيع هذا يحتاج الى اشهر طويله
وهذا يعني انه لا يوجد لا توجد مركزيه في
اتخاذ القرار في وجه السيار وهذه المشكله
في هذا الموضوع سيد الهام همم لينك من
المقرر انه سيزور بكين قريبا هذا على
الاقل ما تحدثت به همم تسريبات من الصين
وكذلك من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بعد
هذه العقوبات ما المنتظر من موقف الصين من
هذه الزياره حبوب من علاقاتها عموما مع
واشنطن
جزيلا على دعوتكم الكريمه اخي الحقيقه
يعني اتناقد في سياسات الخارجيه الامريكيه
واضحه مهما كانت في
ولايه دونالد ترامب او في ولايه لحالي
لرئيس وفي الحقيقه يعني هذا تناقض يعبر عن
الخلافات بين القوى السياسيه المختلفه في
ما احنا كانت في البيت الابيض او في
الكندره الرئيس الامريكي او في الجهات
اخرى من لو همم الوزارات وبالاضافه الى
ذلك يعني اجابه على سؤالك فبالنسبه الى
الدفع او اعاده الدفع العلاقات الثنائيه
بين الصين والاولايات المتحده لاعتده هذه
العمليه سيكون بشكل سريع جدا نظرا
للخلافات كبيره بين الصين وهؤلاء الولايات
المتحده خصوصا في مواضيع التجاره
المفروضه حاليا من الجانب الامريكي على
شركات الصينيه وعلى الماسورين كبار
المسؤولين الصينيين وبالاضافه الى ذلك
يعني اا في بعض المحللين يقول هذه سياسه
سياسه الجزره والعصر القديمه التي تلعبها
همم الولايات الامريكيه في سكرني الماضي
ولكن انا ارى ان هذا هذه السياسه تعكس على
ضعف الولايات المتحده خاصه بالمجالس
السياحي يعني الان بنسبه للام المواجهه
بين الولايات المتحده والصين همم السلاح
الوحيد بنسبه للبيت الابيض هو ما يسمى
بحقوق الانسان ولكن في الحقيقه يعني هذه
همم هذه اللعب لن تقبلها الجمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه وفي الحقيقه يعني كما نرى كانت
هناك عقوبات امريكيه تجاهها الصين وفي نفس
الوقت يعني بعد ايام قليله هناك عقوبه من
قبل الصين على الولايات المتحده مهما كان
على شركات همم
وعلى فكره القانون هذا اا اي ده هو
الحسبان الجمهوري والديمقراطي
وقع عليها اوباما وقع على تنفيذه ترامب
القانون يعني متبنى من الاداره الامريكيه
بطريقه عمله ولكنكم اتفقتما على انه ما
تقوم به الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هو
نوع من التضارب في الافعال والاقوال ولكن
اسمح لي ان اطرح عليك دكتور حسين وجهه نظر
مختلفه البعض يقول بان الاداره الامريكيه
تعلم جيدا ما تفعل بالعكس هي تحسب كل
افعالها واقوالها واستعملت هذه الطريقه
صله الحرب البارده اسقطت بها الاتحاد
السوفيتي والكتله الشرقيه فهل يمكن ان
تنجح هذه المره مع الصين ان تفعل ما لا
تقول وتقول ما لا تفعل وتضارب بين اقوالها
بين اللطف والعنف هل تنجح هذه المره تعتقد
لا اعتقد انه الولايات المتحده ترغب في
يعني مواجهه الصين بنفس الطريقه التي
واجهت فيها الاتحاد السوفيتي لم تصل
الشراكه التجاريه بين الاتحاد السوفيتي
والولايات المتحده الى نصف ماوصلت عليه مع
الصين ولكن واضح ان هناك شعور معادي للصين
وهناك اجماع على هذا الشعور في داخل
واشنطن بين الحزبان الجمهور يقدم
من باب الاشتراء هذا اعداء تكونا على مدى
عقود تتهم الولايات المتحده الصين
بسرقه التكنولوجيا بعدم احترام يعني همم
حقوق الملكيه الفكريه الصناعه الامريكيه
وهذه اثارت مشكله كبيره اثارها المسؤول
الامريكيون مع النظارهم الصينيين على مدى
العقود الماضيه ويبدو ان هناك يعني سئم
امريكي وقرار بالمواجهه في هذا الموضوع
تحديدا وهذا الذي يثير غضب الحزبين
الامريكيين في مواجهه الصين ولكن هذا لا
يعني ان هناك
نيه بقطع العلاقات فورا
وحتى لو حاول اي من الطرفين قطعا ستحتاج
الى سنوات يعني حتى تتراجع الضغط ام يقطع
العلاقات بقدر ما هي تطمح لاضعاف الصين
حتى ان بعض المراقبين يقولون بان اضعاف
وتحجيم الصين قد ياتي من الداخل سيد الهام
ما رايك في هذه النقطه مراقبون امريكيون
ومحللون يقولون بان همم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تتعمد اسلوب الضغط لاحداث الضغط
بالعقبات لاحداث التوتر من الداخل مثل ما
فعلت في مناطق اخرى هل تنجح مع الصين
طبعا لا هذا هذه افكار خيالي بالنسبه لبعض
السياسيين الامريكان سيف الحقيقه يعني
مهما كان بداخل الحزب الشعبي الصيني او
داخل اغلبيه المواطنين لشعب الصيني يعني
الاجابه واضحه بان السياده والمصلحه
الوطنيه فوق كل شيء وبلاضافه الى ذلك يعني
ان اوافق على ضيفنا من واشنطن بان هناك
الترابط تقوي الاتجاه خصوصا في مجال تجاري
بين الصين والولايات المتحده لذلك هناك
تناقض في المصلحه ال- همم الاقتصاديه
والسياسات الخارجيه او السياسات
الخارجيه او سياسه التجاريه في الحقيقه في
العصر الحالي يعني لا يمكن ان تتطور
الولايات المتحده
الاقتصادها بدون الدول الاخرى نحنا كانت
لصين او لمملكه العربيه السعوديه
وكذلك دكتور حسين وسؤال حظرتك دكتور حسين
ان كنا نتحدث على متانه علاقات اقتصاديه
لهذه الدرجه وعدم قدره الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان تفصل نفسها على العالم
الصيني انصح التعبير طيب سؤال بديه ما
الذي توده واشنطن من الصين بهذه العقوبات
او بالاحرى ما الشكل الامثل بالنسبه
لواشنطن ان تكون عليها الصين تريدها ان
تكون اقتصاديه همم معها ولكن همم سياسييا
عسكريا غير قويه ما الذي تريده بالتحديد
ما تريد الولايات المتحده من الصين غالبا
من معظم الدول ولكن من الصين خصوصا ان
تكون الصين شريكا تجاريا ولكن تلعب حسب
قوانين الولايات المتحده ومجموعه الدول
زائد سبعه ان في مواضيع التجاره او في
مواضيع التكنولوجيا او في مواضيع التعامل
السياسي وحقوق الانسان ما الى ذلك اعتقد
انه الولايات المتحده الى اليوم لم تحسم
نوعيه العلاقه مع الشركاء التجاريين او
الاصدقاء او حتى الحلفاء هل هم يعني هم هل
الاصدقاء الحلفاء يشبهون الى الولايات
المتحده يتطابقون معها في الشؤون الداخليه
والخارجيه المهم الخلفاء لانه هناك مصلحه
قوميه للولايات المتحده في التحالف مع هذه
الدول فهذا الموضوع طبعا هو الموضوع قديم
ولم يحسب اليه وهناك دائما انقسام بين
الامريكيين انه هل يعني نسعى ان يكونوا
متطابقين معنا او نقول انه مصلحتنا هناك
ولا يهمنا ماذا يمارسون في الداخل وهذا
موضوع يتعلق بسياده من الموضوع بالنسبه
للصين سيد الهام هل يمكن الصين ان تبني
شعرك اقتصاديه حقيقيه مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بغض النظر عن العقوبات او ان
لهذه العقوبات اثارها او قد تنسحب كذلك
وتوتر العلاقات الدبلوماسيه الاقتصاديه
تجاريه
لذلك يعني مع ضغوط سياسيه والعسكريه
الامريكيه على جمهوريه الصين شعبيه اعتقد
منها صعب ان يكون هناك يعني على قاده
المدينه خصوصا في مجال الاقتصاد والتجاره
بين الصين والولايات المتحده بالاضافه الى
ذلك يعني دائما نقول هناك همم الضغوط همم
الولايات المتحده على الصين وهذه
العقوبات او تخوت من اجل اضعاف الصين همم
في الحقيقه تجاريه والاقتصاديه
وخاصه شركه هواوي
الاقتصاديه مع واشنطن هي رفاهيه كذلك قد
تكون ملزمه بعكس ذلك هل يمكن لي همم
من هذه الناحيه
نعم في الحقيقه يعني الحكومه الصينيه ترغب
او عبرت بعده مرات لرغبتها في تحسين
العلاقات مهما كانت سياسيا والاقتصاديه مع
الولايات المتحده خصوصا في اللقاء الاخيره
خلال قمه مجموعه العشرين في جزيره بالي
بين فخامه الرئيس الصيني ورئيس الامريكي
ولكن في الحقيقه مع زياره نائب وزيره
خارجيه الامريكيه الى الصين هذه العقوبات
المفروض على شركه كبار المسؤولين الصينيين
سيكلل اهميه هذا
الامريكي
ممكن يدعى ظل همم يعني تاثيره سلبي جدا
لزياره
الى الصين في الاوائل المقبل
هذه العقوبات هل يمكن يمكن
بانه هي تمر بخمسه ادارات سياديه ولكن همم
امكانيه تحويرها بما سيتلاءم مع ظروف
تقارب السياسي ممكن
اعتقد انها منفصله عن التقارب السياسي وهي
ترتبط حصا بسبب فرضها وهم اعلن وحقوق
الانسان اذا هي لن ترفع ما لم تستوفي شروط
يعني تراجع المسؤلان عن الممارسات التي
تزعم الولايات المتحده انهما يقولون بها
بنفسها دائما واشنطن هي القاضي والحاكم في
مجال حقوق الانسان يعني الموضوع دائما
يعادل دائره التساؤلات همم ليست الامثل
ولا هي النموذج همم اللي لا يشهد تجاوزات
داخليه طالت التجاوزات حتى رؤساء وزارهها
وحكمها فلماذا تضع نفسها حاكم قاضي همم
على هذا الملف او او السؤال لماذا تنتقل
يعني ايران
يعني تنتهي هؤلاء لم تفرض عليهم
وهذا طبعا بحكمه في نفسها ههه ربما سنه
اكتشفها او نحاول على الاقل في الايام
القادمه
الشكر من الرياضه الصحفيه الصيني الهاملي
ومن واشنطن دكتور حسين عبد الحسين المحلله
السياسي شكرا لكم
الى فاصل من بعدها سنعود دي نتابع
تهديدات اردوغان لليونان الدوله العضو في
الناتولا الاتحاد الاوروبي جديه ام
استعراضيه انتخابيه
[موسيقى]